هذه ميكو لايف المدينه المشهوره بصيانه
السفن في البحر الاسود تعيش الحرب لما
يزيد عن ثمانيه اشهر وتعاني الامرين
لقربها من خط النار ومرمى المدفعيه
الروسيه التي تستهدف المجانين والبنيه
التحتيه روسيه لا توجد كهرباء ولمياه
ولكن هذا افضل من ان نعيش تحت الاحتلال
الروسي
اوكرانيا
فذلك قلل القصف على ميكو لايف هذا يعني
لان الكثير نعم توجد مشاكل في الطاقه
لكننا لن نستسلم ولن نعيش في ظل الروس
وسننتصر المجد لاوكانيا
وعاطفيا على الحلول التي يبتكرونها نحن
الان في احدى الخيام التي نصبت لمساعده
الاوكرانيين لتجاوز الازمه هذه الخيمه هي
مزوده
مولد كهرباء وايضا بالتدفئه كما تشاهدون
هنا
وكذلك يمكن لي المواطنين ان ينعموا بكوب
من الشاي الساخن طبعا تعلمون ان درجه
الحراره الان في اوكرانيا وفي مدينه ميكا
لايف هي دول الصفر ياتي المواطنين الى هذه
الخيام لشحنه هواتفهم النقاله
وايضا لينعم بالتدفئه التي يفتقدونها في
منازلهم
اتيت الى هنا لاعمل هكذا هو الظرف ويجب ان
اكون على اتصال بالشبكه للعمل
مزيدا من هذه المراكز على الاقل في كل حي
لان الناس ياتون الى هنا من احياء اخرى
وكما ترون هنا ازدحام كبير وبسببه تحتاج
الى وقت طويل لشحن هاتفك
معاناه اخرى تضاف الى معاناه الاخرانين
ياتي المواطنين الى هنا بشكل يومي لتعبئه
المياه الصالحه للشرب هذه النقاط وضعت من
قبل الدوله فياتي المواطنين ويقومون
بتعبئه المياه ونقلها الى منازلهم وكما
تشاهدون الاغلبيه من كبار السن
اقوم بنقل المياه لانه لا يوجد ماء في
المنزل وننتظر ان يعيد توصيل المياه
الصالحه
لا يوجد من يساعدني لكن ذلك لا
يهمكس بشكل ايجابي على مدينه ميكا لايف
القريبه منها فقد بدا القصف الصاروخي
المستمر بشكل يومي الا ان هذا الهدوء
الحذر لم يكن كافيا لعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها لقناه العربيه والحدث فكيف عادي